the next interview with President Levin
will be stepping down in June after 20
years of running the University you've
been interviewed by 24 editor-in-chief's
one from the beginning of his turn at
one from the end of his term Paul
Needham and Emily Nelson great thank you
for being with us this afternoon hello
everybody great to be here we're gonna
use this as a chance to look back look
forward and then we'll also open it up
to questions from everyone at the end so
to start off Gail presents so
differently today from when you took
office it was a mid just a host of
challenges and so looking back on that
how did you define what you were going
to tackle first set the priorities and
kind of put us on the track yeah no
thanks well you know if you go back and
read what I said on the day I was
announced as the president in april of
nineteen ninety-three or my na ghal
address i actually had a pretty coherent
program um that i've spent about 20
years executing and that the components
were more or less repair the
relationships with the city of New Haven
and transform Yale from ivory tower to a
core to a model corporate citizen to do
something to you know repair the
condition of the buildings which were in
terrible state of dilapidation to
rebalance Yale's intellectual portfolio
in the direction of science not to say
that we would deprive the humanities in
the arts which have long been a strength
but to bring science up so that we would
be more competitive with our peer
institutions in that domain and to
internationalize the university and then
there was some also some material about
keeping you know expanding access to the
great treasures of Yale by expanding
financial aid that was
see the program and actually that's
exactly what I've been doing for 20
years so um but it was clear what had to
be done first we were running a budget
deficit um the facilities were in
terrible condition um we actually
couldn't afford at that moment to really
start heavily investing in the
facilities so we went into a planning
mode and for about the first two and a
half years there was a systematic effort
to organize the campus into various
components the arts area was one on the
residential colleges and other athletic
facilities another the libraries were
another medical complex and we basically
developed capital plans for the entire
campus and of course the first two or
three years and we didn't yet have the
resources to do very much about it and
then of course market kept going up and
up in the 90s and we were we were able
to begin to invest in by the mid to late
90s the the thing we started in right
away as the first priority was was New
Haven and because that seemed to me that
we really need this signal a
wholehearted commitment to sort of
improving conditions uh in the city but
it was really you know yay was really
being penalized in admissions results
and and in our national reputation by
the what was then a very high crime rate
in the city and by the and by the sense
that this was a kind of demoralized
community and in fact the reality was in
in the early 90s there were many vacant
storefronts in the downtown the there
were there just been a New Yorker
article Bill Finnegan who then went on a
book so I about you know teenage gangs
that book had been written about any
city in America but it was written about
New Haven and written about essentially
the dwight neighborhood which is
immediately adjacent to campus so that
was a problem GQ published an article
right after I took office basically
saying that Yale was about the day
called the death of Yale and and so we
really needed to address both for the
external audience but were fundamentally
to really sort of change conditions in
New Haven so we started right away with
a whole series of initiatives in the
first year the most important initiative
was
hiring Linda lorimer to do this and and
we took it quite a distance in the first
couple of years and then realized the
next job was real estate development
developed in downtown and I brought in
Bruce Alexander who did a magnificent
job with that we're gonna talk about all
that we're going to talk about Linda
lorem we're going to talk about versa
examine let's talk about you also which
was Emily's question was how does the
campus present differently and how do
you think you present differently how do
you think you've changed in 20 years I
think I'm a much better speaker uh if
you I was terrible I mean I really it's
embarrassing to go back and look at the
early years i just i visited way too
much out on my toes I you know videos
great it helps you learn so I got better
and more relaxed I realized I didn't
have to or rate I could just talk so you
know in a normal tone of voice I think
it was much more for me much more
effective style so I think you know and
I mean I think always dressed up okay
but but what about as a manager I I had
pretty good instincts for that all
through my life actually I mean I sort
of was president of everything you know
coming growing up like a lot of Yale
kids and like a lot of of people and um
so I had I think I pretty good said we
had been shared the Economics Department
and understood that academic management
you know required of white a lot of
psychological savvy it's not just
organizational skills you have to really
understand people and you know
particularly when your mannequin
department is very challenging thing to
do because you got these incredibly
talented people it's probably like good
I mean journalism must be similar you
try to organize a group of really
talented people who get where they are
because of their individualistic and
because they're excellent at what they
do but not because they're necessarily
team players and and so you know
learning how to I got very good
experience miadora department chair in
learning how to bring people together
with disparate point of view what's of
you who didn't sort of instinctively
care about the community they cared more
about their individual
well being and so get being a bring
people together so might I think I'd
probably developed best as a department
chair and why retire now why did this
feel like the right time well 20 years
is a good round number it's it's um I
mean it's a slightly a joke but it's
sort of serious too I tried to think
about what would it be like we had a big
gala celebration in 2003 at my 10th
anniversary as president and I thought
so what happens in april of saving last
summer what happens in april when it's
my 20th anniversary and if I haven't
announced I'm leaving that's the only
thing people are going to be thinking
about like how much longer is he going
to be here so it's there was a kind of
natural rhythm it seemed it also seemed
like in terms of the cycle of
accomplishing things that a number of
you know we just finished a big capital
campaign you run these things sort of
you know it's you should be launching
the next campaign beginning to at least
planet no less than no more than five
years after the previous one and you
know if you're going to go into another
campaign cycle that means another seven
years and you know I did know I'm mostly
going to take hold this job so I was 75
that was clear so so I thought that was
a natural reason we had we had some big
things had been completed in terms of
you know launching the Singapore campus
which I felt now was in good hands we
had a fabulous leader out there and that
really was great momentum um and I
thought it's a probably good a time as
there will be to pass the baton there
also you know the major goals of
internationalized in the University and
in repairing new haven and and kind of
improving science they were all sort of
well underway and it seemed like the
next era was going to be how is Yale
going to hell yell cope with the online
revolution that it seemed like there was
another big project out there that
probably required a ten-year perspective
to really to really do a good job with
it and I really believe you want to
finish things you start or at least get
farl on the road and so that's another
reason so all in all just added up and I
sort of gradually came to this
realization of the course of the summer
and announced on 30th of August I have
two questions yeah the first which
someone jest you've said before that
President Elliot from Harvard is your
hero in your role model he served 40
years do you think the era in which
anyone could lead almost any
organization for 40 years is over not
necessarily I mean if I if if I'd
started this job at 35 like Elliot did I
would have gone I mean I'm 65 now I
wouldn't go on 30 you know I think very
likely um it's just um but I so I mean
you have to love it though I mean there
are very few my colleagues really love
this job this kind of job I mean they
they know what's important there
dedicated they're really committed I
mean most of the university presidents
that I know are fabulously great people
but um they find you know most people if
I it wears them down over time I that
was never my problem I I sort of somehow
I mean for whatever reason I thrived in
mostly its I like the job I like doing
it you've said online education is maybe
the biggest challenge facing Peter
Salomon you think you relate to that
question do you think you could have
started that process and Yale could have
taken that more seriously sooner we did
we I mean we were we were earlier in
this than anybody just you know in
another scale though no not at scale but
in the internet bubble yet you know
before the internet bubble burst we were
you know we've started all learn we were
we were in there with Stanford and
Oxford and this with this online
experiment we did the open Yale courses
right on the heels of the MIT
OpenCourseWare but all they were doing
at that point was putting reading lists
up and and and problem sets and we put
on you know live video really excellent
video of full lecture courses and you
know had them transcribed and translated
and so I think we were definitely in the
game um you know the the last little
this what John Hennessy calls the
tsunami you know it came on in a rush I
mean in my view kind of premature it
inchoate rush I mean so Coursera and
Udacity
you ex get found within the span of six
months and people started signing up and
look at it that's already the game is
Cain Sanford announces joining EDX now
they were the ones that started Coursera
backed off from being the principal
investor in it now they're joining EDX I
don't this is I was a student of
technological change and how industries
evolved that was my subject in economics
where the we're just at the beginning of
something that's going to be workable at
scalar that's going to have a revenue
model to sustain it and there's going to
be it isn't going to look like what it
looks like now and MOOCs may not be I
mean that is to say the very large
courses that may not turn out to be the
best way to do this I mean to really get
education out of it as opposed to just
exposure to content you really have to
figure out ways to to evaluate students
to certify them um that may take more
human input then the current model
allows so I think it's a great problem
I'm adding it's exciting I think Yale
should be in it and we are we are
working on multiple platforms we
actually taught nine summer school
courses last summer completely online
with with grades with mentoring with
professors online with the students and
we charge three thousand dollars of
course I mean not the fifty dollars that
you're these massive courses are talking
about so um you know there are going to
be different ways to cope with there's a
whole bunch of different levels and
models that will work and will be fun I
think it'd be fun for Yale to explore it
Oh is there anyone who you're looking at
and thinking oh they're doing it well
does he look at um I like the Coursera
people I think I mean I think they're I
think they're impressive and ruin and
Daphne and their and their kind of in
their visionary in their enthusiastic
they've got the right entrepreneurial
spirit and I think the brains and the
flexibility thing I've admired about
them is they have changed their story in
about every two months because they
learn things and they're not embarrass
tuck with an idea they're they're nimble
and so you know I I would not be
surprised that they're survivors in this
game but um but I think the model will
evolve and it I also thought we have
didn't have to hurry
sign up for one of these we have a great
brand and we didn't have to be first in
the gate I mean it would have cost 30
million dollars to join headaches a year
ago it causes your own joint etics now
hitting on another thing that you've
discussed which is the globalization and
um you talk about that you're putting
out you know educated global citizens
what do you mean by that expression how
do you what sort of the Yale student you
want to send off so you know we I
pursued this very you know right from
the beginning the first move was to try
to expand the number of international
students in you know college and then
later when we were in better economic
circumstances we went to need-blind
admissions of international students and
a real concerted effort to get every
Yale student overseas and the impetus
behind it occasionally is starts from a
recognition that we live in the globally
connected world that to be an effective
and functioning person in almost any
walk of life certainly journalism in
business in education on the planet the
professions a little less so yet but
it's going to happen you're going to
need the ability to relate to people
with different cultural backgrounds you
see the world in a different way from
oneself and so I sort of thought early
on that that we need to think about how
do we develop in students a capacity for
cross-cultural understanding and you
know just having roommates suitemates
from overseas as a start just you know
having more exposure for instance well
some of you went here at a time when
literally only two percent of the class
was international one in 50 and when I
started it was three percent it's very
different when it's ten percent I mean
because everyone now goes do calc today
has among their best friends an
international student and so I think
that's a start and then of course
immersion in a foreign country spending
time there ideally with the language
really helps you understand that people
see the world differently the
assumptions people make about where the
world works
differ and if you're going to end up
part in partnership with these folks and
educational partnerships and business
partnerships and legal dealings on
whatever it is you're going to really be
advantaged if you have had that
experience in a deep way at least once
because once you've had it and you
understand oh I get it what I'm saying X
that person is thinking why because they
think about the world in a different way
once you've mastered that capacity I
really think you can you can apply it in
multiple contexts and that's I think
that's to be a good citizen in the
century fact an effective person to sent
in the century you're going to need that
skill the citizen part is a little goes
a little farther and that's that's more
rooted in a notion that Yale has always
tried to educate people for service to
society and for leadership in society
and I think we just have to recognize in
this highly interdependent world the
nation is is an increasingly artificial
construct that that so many of the
problems of the world so many of the
dealings that one will have in the world
we're going to cut across international
boundaries and jurisdictions and you
know the obvious problem the common
goods problems like global warming
require global cooperation and and so we
always talked about you know the AL
being a citizen of the nation but I
think you have to think about being a
citizen the nation and a citizen of the
planet in the 0 so obviously your desire
with the Singapore project is to head
down that road and to address that
question of how does Yale fit into the
world my question on that is you've said
before that Harvard is like hurts and
yells like Avis and that we have to try
harder explain from a strategic
standpoint how does the Singapore
project fit into your overall sense of
Yale's place in the world yeah so the
Singapore project is is is really was a
natural next step having having
basically established this notion that
Yale students go overseas the other
piece of its students come here our
curriculum here at home had been has
been much strengthened in the
international dimension we we were
looking at this had the the expansion of
the faculty in
in the decade before the bubble for the
boot you know for the financial crisis
essentially all of the increment in the
size of the faculty was in two
categories and diversity and in an
internationalization um a little bit in
engineering to and and that um so that
was accomplished and that did seem you
know the next the next step was really
to think can we can we really think
about in making a significant
improvement in the quality of 21st
century education um bye-bye really
serious curriculum innovation that
responded when you think okay we're
going to start from scratch and think
about what does a 21st century global
citizen need to know and how should they
be educated you know we had a curriculum
reform and started at the tur centennial
2001 completed in 2003 committee chaired
by dick broadhead who's as good at as
good an educator as you can find many
which you told me a few years ago you
didn't think had to happen at the
beginning at the beginning I didn't
think had to happen at the beginning
because and I and I think in the end I
agree it didn't have to happen because
they do very much I mean if you if you
if you look at the outcome there were
some modest incremental improvements and
if you stop it the best thing about that
committee like the like the committee
that that on which dick broadhead
Allison Richard and a number of the rest
of other people who became university
leaders served in the late 80s Early 90s
was that it brought together the Rising
Stars of the faculty and gave them a
leadership opportunity and so that
provided the that's where so many of the
people Peter salad a and and and Andy
Hamilton and a whole lot of others got
first got their teeth on university-wide
problem but the but the actual result
was pretty modest in terms of real
change in the curriculum and the reason
for that is in a university has
established as ours and frankly as good
as ours um you know that it produces the
turf battles I mean people you know the
department wants its claim on
the number of required courses to be
reduced everybody is thinking a little
bit too parochial e about how to get
this done and so the change is
incremental I'm we did something was
very good i mean some of it was
excellent and I think we have enhanced
for example the writing programs have
really improved over the last decade but
I I was thinking more boldly and and so
how do you experiment and starting up is
a way to do it and starting up
internationally in partnership with an
international institution was seemed
like exactly the right thing to do
because rather than do it all by
ourselves because in a way because there
are two competing organizations that are
sort of behind it you have to confront
the fundamental questions you know you
know if you all went over at the
presumption it's just going to be a
model of what we do here we're going to
place we're going to plop it down
overseas which is the NYU model by the
way I don't and that's not to disparage
it it's a perfectly that's a they're
doing a good service I think to their
own students by having campuses that
essentially replicate NYU and three or
four places around it hello but this is
a very much more radical proposition
which was which was let's just start
over on redesign what we should do and
the document just came out this thursday
the really fabulous report that gives a
comprehensive explanation for the new
curriculum and the rationale for it III
mean it starts at the deepest level
about what what are the elements of of a
liberal education in the 21st century
both in terms of content in terms of
organization I mean it makes the case
for a quote for a common curriculum
that's been made many times but is only
succeeded in a few instances we survived
in a few instances in this country where
at Yale and us all students will take 12
of their 32 courses in common um which
creates a whole opportunity for
essentially this common experience audit
deep and the education of everyone it
makes the dinner table conversations
more interesting you know yeah but you
have you have a fundamental
correspondence of what people
are exposed to and then the you know
talks about the pedagogy which is which
is you know novelty for Asia the kind of
pedagogy we're used to small class
discussion active participation the
notion of questioning not only
classmates but the instructor you know
not just this polite recitation so that
was fundamental for Asia but that's a
integral part of the success of this of
this curriculum and then the
confrontation of values and cultures on
the other key element in this curriculum
is that that Asian and you know what
Western ideas will come into just to
position and we you know Aristotle and
Confucius were contemporaries and their
works will be read together uh in this
curriculum so anyway there's a wonderful
document which I commend to you it was
just released on Thursday that I think
you know if yell 1828 reports were the
seminal document about liberal education
in the 19th century the Harvard read
book in 1945 probably the most important
statement of liberal arts education in
the 2020s century I think it's a really
significant chance that this yale-nus
report will be the document for the for
the 21st century and that's that's not
just saying we're producing a great
institution in Asia and not just saying
that we're going to transform the
curriculum a nation which I think we are
I mean I really think this will there's
a tremendous hunger for liberal
education in Asia and for moving away
from the highly specialized almost
vocational training that occurs in your
in Asian universities toward a more
flexible liberal arts education but I
think it'll spill back I mean you
couldn't have done this frontally what
will happen is Yale people will go over
and teach at Singapore and they will
bring back World War II we've already
been developing the curriculum is I mean
a 15 or 20 of our faculty been very
intimately involved and you can start
new you know of course by course some of
the innovations that we're going to take
in Singapore come back to New Haven and
who knows where that will go well I'm
real optimist I think it's a fantastic
experiment would this cleaned up and I'm
just thinking back to all the opposition
and issues around this earlier on
the opposition was really tune of the
worries about is are the political
constraints in Singapore the fact that
it is not an environment is conducive to
freeze political speech or certainly
frias political assembly that that that
that would constrain the educational
environment and yes it mean in all
honesty it will have some it will impose
some constraint on the educational
environment but it's also the case that
you know if you go visit these places
first of all you see Singapore as a
society in evolution um it is it is
liberalizing significantly already and
second that the campus there's nothing
about being on any OS campus that makes
you feel like you're in in some kind of
society that represses free expression
people talk as openly in as honestly to
one another and in the classroom and
then their academic writings as they do
here so I think it's going to I think
it's going to be fine you know I think
it'll work out okay let's talk about
Peter salebuy your successor and what
I'm curious about he's been your Provost
for what five years for four years what
have you to disagreed on in those four
years how does it good question um you
know it's not like that but I hope very
little actually I mean I think we I kind
of a problem solver I like to talk
things out so most of the in various
small groups but officer team the
academic leadership group the FAS during
executive committee I mean we we hash
things out and we you know almost
inevitably come to agreement so while we
might start out in a different place
about who should have this job or what
should we do about this particular
problem i think we mind up can you know
we get to the answer and so there aren't
there's no real sustained disagreements
between Peter and me I think we're I
think we've been working as a team I'm
not trying to get you to criticize him
but I do know but do you like way too
much
do you think there's an argument that
there would have been value in having a
president paired either from the outside
or someone who hadn't been part of your
core team you could make that argument I
think the search committee went around
and around on that and and as they
should I mean what would you have said
if you were on the search money well
what I did say the search committees
really should look very rigorously
outside I I mean I thought that was the
right thing to do um even if it did lead
to the selection of an internal
candidate and and I think that that's
really incumbent upon trustees to to try
to get the very best person they
possibly can and they looked at some
they looked at some very serious and
qualified candidates you can tell us
those names later yeah I don't even know
them with that I mean you're talking
about sort of some relationships that
that were important during your
presidency can you think of one kind of
unexpected friendship that helped shape
any particular critical moments for you
well i mean i i've got i've become
friends with so many people and so and i
guess most of them weren't unexpected i
mean they're natural my team is an
incredible team the corporation fellows
were given incredible support um I mean
I suppose what the unexpected friendship
maybe John DeStefano I would be would
qualify because who would the mayor of
New Haven yeah who would have expected
that that the mayor and the president of
Yale would have would have served
together for 20 years both and
accomplished so much together this is
not always the smoothest relationship
John DeStefano is a is kind of a stormy
personality Michael knows well I worked
for him but John is um you know he can
be quite volatile but you know he is a
person who cares passionately about
making this a better City and and um so
he in one way is a real idealist because
he really holds out yuly wants to make
the world better
um and on the other hand he's a very
good pragmatist and and and he he
recognizes in the end sometimes it takes
a while but that there's a lot that can
be accomplished through the partnership
with Yale and that we can as a practical
matter really move the city forward and
we have so many so many successful
initiatives and so many ways in which i
think we have made the place better that
you know and we are friends and we part
than when after all this thing i think
we both have grown very fond of each
other even though were incredibly
different personalities one more
expected friendship because she picked
you she was on the search committee that
picture is is Lyn Delorme and tell me
about that friendship and that working
relationship I can't say enough good
things about mental armor I mean she is
just the best I mean there's she was on
the search committee she interviewed me
in the first time the first round of
interviews was basically the search
committee touching base with lots of
different people you know who talked to
hundreds of people that impact
particularly then in 1992 the on that
summer and fall um there you know the
place was kind of in consternation and
and so I so Bob Lin who's in the
audience who was chair of the search
committee where are you Bob is right
here Bob Lin and lindell armor
interviewed me in July of 1992 this just
in when they were taking soundings about
the place and I came away from that
interview thinking if I am so lucky is
to get this job I am hiring that woman
okay I'm bringing her back here she was
she had been an associate general
counsel and associate provost under Bart
Giamatti and then she'd gone off at age
34 to be president of randolph-macon
women's college and she was and then was
elected to the Oh corporation as an
alumni fellow and so um when I so I
actually pretty much made up my mind I
want to hire this person at that very
moment and of course I followed up on it
right away I mean I never said a word
about it while the search was going on
or
or even confess the idea to anybody but
please don't get the wrong idea but but
after it was all done you know maybe a
few hours uh we had the actually she
dropped a handkerchief before I even had
a chance to say it she told someone and
woodbridge all that she might be
interested so it was it was clear that
this was going to be great she had she
is a she's been a strategic partner from
the first day she says she's as smart as
anybody in this campus and she's armed
and she has the kind of nimble mind it
will that that what likes to test out
possibilities and think through you know
if you did a or b or c and what are the
collateral consequences is a problem
solver and a strategic thinker and and
we have a we just get a tremendous
amount and we speak basically and half
sentences but at this point but we
because we understand what the Owens
going to finish how he was going to
finish the sentence but we really really
are able to advance each other's things
so there's the strategic partnership
part of it that's fabulous and then
there's she's the best operating
executive I've ever seen and I've seen a
lot and I've got great people and she
just if you give her a task she has an
uncanny ability to mobilize people to
motivate them and to get it done and so
basically it was I brought her in to
handle New Haven but I basically given
her every major university you know
university initiative sense i mean we
once once something gets mature we hand
it off to someone else and then she fit
them and she takes over something new
and she's just a great startup
entrepreneur but also an Orchestrator of
large-scale activities on the
international stuff now and you know she
organized the terse antonia program and
she's just amazing and i know you're a
big fan of hers too and i think she it's
been it's been the incredible
partnership i'd say and i have had great
revenue academic side i've had of course
phenomenal Provost's of all going on to
lead major institutions and they're all
they mean they're all spectacular as
well so it's it's been very lucky had
great great people to work with so we
wanted
you um okay no not yet a couple more fun
to do three more cause you guys were
perfectly coordinated at first just
quickly will the tuna colleges be built
and when I'm confident they will be
built and and will there be people
living in tuner colleges in 2019
September 2019 I would bet on it yeah
yeah second what's next for you this is
that her question what's next for me see
well I another what's next is to think
about what's next that is I've
deliberately avoided trying to plan out
you know what I'm going to do next in
detail many wise people who've left jabs
leadership jobs have said don't you know
give yourself six months to a year
that's before you say yes to anything
and so I you know I've had a number of
people from approaching with a number of
ideas and of course one idea is to stay
right here and teach economics again but
uh there are I mean I'm just gonna take
my time I have a sabbatical coming i
haven't had a year a leave since 1986
and jane and are going to go out to
Stanford for the fall semester where you
know we were both undergraduates and
where our son teaches and a daughter in
San Francisco and all the other two kids
are in LA and seattle so all the whole
families on the west coast and so it'll
be nice to just have more family time
and do some writing and thinking and
sort of decide what i wanna do when I
grow up you know you talk about the
writing part of it was it one I think it
was your announcement said it was going
to be a book on higher education
economic policy what you sent it like a
very long that was probably what the
Yale Daily News Nutella telling that's
how they got it
I don't think they'd be the same book
but I I do there are some things i want
to write I just public I've just
published book yesterday of the
oppressed which is a collection of
speeches and essays in fact the
motivation for doing that book so fast
was Linda lormer when she read the thing
in the Yale Daily News about how I was
going to write a book on higher
education he says you're going to write
a book so i have to give us party favors
in April and May when we have all these
farewell offense and so I say it's okay
so final fully I this is volume 2 of my
collected speeches and that's out now
but the but there are some things some
new things I'd like to write about um we
were just talking before this about a
natural management of universities I'm
actually think I I think there's some
lessons that I've learned there as an
economist than that I think have general
application to how to how to believe you
know the boring stuff not the policy
stuff but it's how did how to do you
know proper proper investment to
maintain facilities on we have developed
a system here at Yale it's unique in the
nonprofit world that does full
replacement cost appreciation of our
buildings so that so that we now
generate enough cash flow every year
that will never if we stick to the
discipline we will never again have the
condition that I inherited that is that
will have an under maintained plan so i
would like to write that up there and I
I in my new book there's a there's one
essay on the economic crisis that's sort
of us based on a talk I've been giving
for the last in philly for the last four
years about what we should what we
should have done you know about what we
should have done right early on and what
we still should do and and I might want
to extend that into a longer maybe not a
full book but a longer we're serious
more serious discussion so there's a
couple things i'll be working on
okay so to wrap it up here and then we
are eager for all of your questions
we'll do a rapid round of ten ten quick
answer questions okay so for the rapid
fire questions okay start it off your
favorite spot on campus I think probably
the courtyard in trumbull College the
best place to think on campus um at home
on everett street off campus okay the
your favorite celebrity visitor to host
to campus Wow they've been so many the
most inspiring was da su who was here
this year absolutely amazing person um
maybe the most fun was Paul Simon who
sang at the true Centennial a Yale
experience no one should graduate
without seeing this art gallery a word
for your state of mind on your first day
as president um I think joyous but
overwhelming a word for your state of
mind on commencement next month I think
I'll be emotional it one of the you
didn't have to be quite this question
but them but they kind of that there's
something just so magical about being up
on the stage at commencement and looking
out over 20,000 people it at the
happiest moment you know when when you
see all these families and graduates it
really brings tears to my eyes every
year it's doing it now it's a it's a
it's beautiful and don't miss that that
was fun that is fun a role model for
your presidency who was a role model for
my presidency Charles Elliott I think it
is I means I've read the history of
higher education I think he's and I and
there's a long essay in my book about
Charles Elliott a role model for your
post presidency
I don't know yet because I you know I
don't know I i would i would like to
keep contributing in various ways to the
public I mean this is the public service
job the way I see it and I think at some
level I want to be an active contributor
long and into life and while I don't
necessarily share the politics of these
people the people like George Shultz and
and Henry Kissinger who remained active
and valuable contributors to the
discussion of public issues you know
well along into their late years of life
are very inspiring to me okay two more
add your what would rank is your most
embarrassing moment as president
embarrassing um I mean I know where I
where I messed up the most but uh but um
hey I um I guess it's a hard like and I
can't really come up with that one I'm
gonna stuck to a pass next one can we
pause for a second you said you knew
where he messed up the most yeah well
that was worse than embarrassing that
was just so where to do mess up the move
the the the whole Lee bass gift fiasco
and the year too um where I just didn't
misread I just didn't misread the
situation and didn't realize how
disaffected the donor was becoming with
the lack of action on implementing the
program that he had wanted to implement
and now that led um i guess it was your
years editor was there was it knows you
yeah yeah well I after yeah um um yeah
and so just it became it became you know
it it worked its way to an end game in
which he made an unreasonable demand on
us which was that he get to approve the
appointment of professors to his program
which actually made it easy for me to
say here's your check back but yet which
made me a hero to the New York Times and
a villain to The Wall Street Journal
interesting but i but i but you know I I
really screwed up there it was not it
was it was it was not I didn't deserve
the accolades with it it's easy to say
no you threw a donor you can't appoint a
professor it's obvious they can't point
a professor it does not consistent with
our values but he didn't have to get to
that point I'm not and I let I let
things deteriorate to that point so it
was a I that wasn't a short answer but
yeah and the and the proudest moment of
your presidency um Oh probably when Jane
won the teaching prize will open to your
questions and we have a good amount of
time for your questions and there are
microphones that you should wait for
because we are being video recorded I
have another question about your
successor you've touched on the
importance of understanding people and
of course your successor is a
psychologist how would you compare your
temperament and your leadership style to
Professor Saliva's temperament and style
we both actually are I think good
listeners and kind of empathetic people
that that relate well to others and on
and try to get the product try to
penetrate what others are saying to
really get it with their thank you um I
mean I I actually think the two
disciplines that are most important to a
leader our economics and psychology and
and and I think Peter really does have
those kinds of skills um and then that
those that's clearly the biggest
similarity the difference the
differences are more you know are not so
much temperamental as just training I
mean I am a it's it's not that he's not
a clear or rigorous thinker he is but
I'm very I'm an economist i mean i
really can i really have a penchant for
braking problems down organizing them
very logically in reasoning my weight
answer and I think Peters a little more
a little more intuitive and not that he
doesn't think things through he does but
it's but I think I think there's some
differences in our roots that way but
you know people are different um
nationally I think there's a widespread
perception that university education are
becoming unaffordable for many people
and for society as a whole as the price
inflates much more rapidly than the cost
of living how long do you think this
could go on and what might slow or stop
or even reverse that pattern there's a
lot of misunderstanding of the of what
of this problem um first of all the
growth in what it costs an individual to
send that would cost a family to send a
child to college has been most dramatic
in the public institutions at least
twice the rate of inflation as in the
private schools and why is that that's
because of the cutbacks in state funding
and why is that that's because the cost
of health care so what you see in state
budgets is a massive shift from spending
on education to expenditure on health
care and and um and so you know
interestingly if you want to control the
costs of public education let's fix the
health care problem um so that meant
that nobody says that but that's my my
it's my view now with respect to the
private institutions you really have two
separate issues when you talk about the
highly selected well endowed
institutions are price to the to the
people who are on financial aid which is
the majority has been falling the
average price paid by paid for Yale
education has gone down 1.1 percent per
year over my tenure adjusted for
inflation because um because our
financial aid program has grown
faster than the then then tuition um so
uh so today you know first of i mean
obviously the low end the the meet the
family of the median US income pays
nothing for yelling education that's not
well understood in the general public
it's hard to get that message out but
the same statement I just made would be
true of Harvard and Princeton and
Stanford and and most of the Ivy League
peers and then the Amerson Williams of
the world too um but it but then there's
a whole chunk of the and of course
that's not true for the full paying
students whose who those families who
can afford it they've seen increases on
the order of inflation plus two percent
a year so over the 20 years um the the
amendment and there are lots and lots of
private institutions that don't have you
know resources to do the kind of
financial aid programs that the top ones
do so it's a it's a little bit more
complicated picture i think that the
technology chain these changes in
technology do afford some hope for
solution the solution could take you
know radical forms like a significant
reduction in the number of residential
institutions it's you know physically
physical university on because we could
see a lot of exit from the from the
existing set of univ colleges and
universities and their replacement by in
a large large scale online enterprises
that actually you know get overtime
start giving degrees and being
substitutes take one or two more maybe
in the back following following up on
that a little bit there was a recent
column by david Leonhardt or no i don't
you think it was by lee and hard about
london by eduardo porter about hawks
bees study that shows that a lot of the
poor students that is poor financially
don't have the knowledge that you just
expressed and in the other sort of the
part below it was that if in fact they
got this knowledge and got in then the
financial aid budgets would go up so I
mean is he L doing any
thing to try to move to try to recruit
students of lower economic means you
know beyond you know what they've been
doing in the past because for my
perspective I teach at a public
institution the Ivy League's have been
you know trying to get their acceptance
rate down by going and recruiting lots
of people probably who are affluent who
they know for sure won't get in you know
so you have like you know all these
college nights and college pressure and
all the mailings and you've li you get a
lot of people that you know you're not
going to take you know so you could say
well we have an eight percent acceptance
rate but from the reading this study it
looks like if you push down you'd find a
lot of people who are not affluent who
would in fact probably be accepted but
would in fact be a higher burden on the
financial aid budget so I'm wondering if
yells thought about that at all well we
feel we think about all time and we
actually have made intensified efforts
to get the word out about our financial
aid programs and two and and we try to
reach those students it's true because
so many of the kind of student that's a
very good paper by carolyn cox we can
press a view by the way and I think it's
really worth reading and thinking about
um but the idea is that your lots of
public school kids out there in not in
the not in the known to be excellent
public schools but in just all over
America who are top of their class who
are real outliers for their communities
who when asked when they ask their
college counselors where should I go
they say the state university they don't
even think about going to the highly
selective institutions and I think that
is a problem enemy and we are doing as
much as we can well I wouldn't say that
we've been doing quite a bit to try to
get to those kids but mainly through
email and you know that kind of contact
as opposed to sending you know
admissions officers the problem with
sending admissions officers to a rural
school in Kansas that might produce a
Yale quality student once every five or
ten years is that it may not be a very
efficient use of time so of the
admissions officers so it's a it's a
trade-off um
it would be great of what we with there
I think the Hawks be Avery paper will
stimulate a lot of discussion among the
IV's and the other selective liberal
arts colleges about maybe um pooling
resources for recruiting and rather than
all going out by ourselves but you know
it's sort of spreading ourselves to just
make make it understood that this
network is available to you I think that
would be a great thing it would be great
consequence of the of their research
which is compelling i think it's i think
it's it's a shame that there are so many
bright kids that don't know what what
they could get the place like this let's
take one more question so speaking of
david leonhardt and it's become
legendary here at the Yale Daily News
the story of how we broke the news that
you were going to be appointed by
president and I've always wanted to ask
what was going through your mind as you
know this reporter accosted you on the
streets of New Haven and and what did
you think when the when you know it was
in the paper the next time I don't think
I said anything that would have given
him a reason to think that they could
they'd give it that they could run that
story actually but John Josh was the one
who actually confronted me right and
it's gosh yeah if isn't about so what's
your why do you how do you remember a
Josh what did I say we're gonna bug
bring about what did I say that tipped
it off
now that you didn't print that you've
been trying to pin it up for 20 years
Josh you've been trying to pin it on me
as though I kids so candy Bryce was the
one huh Wow had no idea that no idea
well that's okay you guys is that is
that good journalistic ethics to conceal
your sources not all right thank you
very much a lot of fun let's say one
minute
watch it what's next we're gonna have an
update on the news from the current
editor on the current publisher and then
we'll have our political discussion with
david gergen and a whole great group of
reporters okay thank you that was fun
thank you
guys congratulations